What if all of my
footage was this close?
Ah, that hurt my stomach I
started laughing so hard.
What?
Like, every single
scene was this close.
Oh my God.
Oh, there goes the camera.
Oh, crap.
OK, calm it down.
That was a moment of insanity.
So with that said,
it's time to get up.
I think today will be
a good day for fishing.
I feel it.
The water's at a
good level today.
Here we go.
That's a good one.
This one got my bait.
I can't wait to take
Campbell fishing.
We'll rent a canoe and go out.
I know he's going to love it.
There we go.
Time with my son is what I look
forward to more than anything
else.
He's not just my son.
He's my friend.
Can't wait to watch
all the amazing things
he's going to do and to be front
and center for all of them.
there we go.
Something's a little bigger.
See, you catch one more, then
you want to keep fishing.
I've got one more
grasshopper in my pocket.
How about I give it
a few more minutes?
My strategy is working basically
exactly as I thought it would.
I am pleasantly surprised
with the amount of fish
I've been able to
pull out of the water.
I wonder if anybody's doing
as well as me with the fish.
Because I would define what
I'm doing as killing the fish.
Good haul.
This one has a big
belly right here.
Wonder why.
It's a small fish and big belly.
This had a really full stomach.
Wow!
I'm gonna have to cut that
open and see what that is.
That thing has been eating.
There's the grasshopper
that was there.
And this is what
else was in there.
You kidding me?
Look at that.
That looks like a mouse.
Let me get it all the way out.
That's incredible.
I don't want to be limited
to how many fish I can hold.
Right now, I am.
I need to try smoking my fish.
So I'll take a
whole line of fish,
string it from one
raft to the other,
and then just keep a good,
smoky fire going all day.
Now after a while, they'll
firm up and find their groove
and they won't slide off.
So we'll be fine.
Everything is perfect right now.
It's really smoking
that stuff up.
Big plumes of direct smoke.
Operation smoke house.